go Bella check trending on Twitter as he
opened up training camp today with a
press conference Dan Shaughnessy of the
Boston Globe he's been with the Boston
Globe since 1981
he's been around a few press conferences
there in Boston showed up today to ask
him about Malcom Butler bill try to turn
the page and as you'll hear Dan will not
only use the do your job line that
Belichick is known for to inoculate
himself from getting the usual rote
we've moved on to Cincinnati answer from
Belichick Ella but he fires off not one
not two not three but I believe a record
for Bill Belichick press conference for
follow up questions in case you missed
it here it is in all its splendor so I
know you're all about this year you
understand here that's right
and I wouldn't be doing my job they
didn't ask about last year last year's
last year I'm not focused on last year
what about the fact that everywhere we
go folks want to ask about Malcolm
Butler
I mean sports coaches players University
you're a sports fan and we talk about
that that's multiple months ago this is
going to be any more explanation about
why he didn't play focused on training
camp do it any differently training camp
of course we're getting started we're
work on that right now we'll do the best
we can and does it matter - do you care
that the fans want to know more about
this I'm focused on doing the best that
I can for the 2018 New England Patriots
that's my job that's what I'm going to
do
that's what I'd always done in the past
every day that I've coached here I've
done the best that I could for this
football team I'll continue to do that
and right now my focus on the 2018
season about 2017 or 2014 of 2007 not
2004 2001 not 2000 not focused on any of
those seasons they're done
this season's team is important for you
to address the Malkin budget thing with
your team it's important for me to have
a good season or 2018 I'm gonna do
everything I can't do that do the best
that I can for our football team that's
my job and that's nice responsibility
that's what I try to do hopefully you
can respect that but maybe not there we
go
Dan Shaughnessy joining us here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you Dan I'm good
how are you I'm fine dude wood now does
that suffice for your cardio for the day
- damn does that do there's like like 15
rounds of Tyson just a minute and 35
seconds you know it's like you got to be
ready and I respect bill and and I
appreciate that he let it go back and
forth a little bit it was sort of the
expected outcome I guess you could say I
feel think it's important to try to get
him on record well I mean he didn't
really I guess answer it the question
but you did at the end ask the million
dollar question is is how will it out
what might have manifest itself in that
locker room are you hearing that there
are some people in that locker room who
are still suiting up for the Patriots
who are questioning to this day what in
the world happened with Malcolm Butler
in the Super Bowl
well there's been stuff you know I mean
everybody's been running at the players
for five and a half months now and
there's been guys saying yeah we wish we
knew and you know back and forth a Brady
was very cryptic about it one of his
paid gigs with Jim Gray where he just
said yeah I wish he'd played and wish we
knew and that kind of thing so yeah I
think that you know that's why when when
bill you know the of course the great
dodge is to say I'm just talking about
this year so I tried to say well it's
part of this year and are you do you
plan to address this with the people in
the room about this year because this is
the first one rich in like 19 years
where there's been some serious pushback
from the devoted fan base the in bill We
Trust people that has been shaken a
little bit because of this decision I
mean he dressed the guy they got gashed
there was arm tackling going on when
they couldn't you know even at his worst
malcom brother can tackle it but he
knows that and so
it just the whole thing doesn't wash and
it's never been explained and and I'm
not saying he's got to reveal everything
I just I just think it's it's it stays
out there it's going to stay there it's
one of the great unsolved mysteries like
I said like Stonehenge and and you know
lost city of Atlantis and those things I
mean we just we don't know it doesn't
add up and it does not appear to have
been in the spirit of doing their best
to win the game and in terms of the
great unknown that that's a void that
usually does get filled with rumor
innuendo conjecture what's the best
guest that you have as to why that did
in fact happen months later dance well
it's amazing I mean you talk to people
that work for the networks and you know
people make runs in that Patricia and
make run said Butler I mean you know the
the resisting the defensive backfield of
Patriots and no one's really getting
anywhere and hey this I mean like like I
said everything's been been put forth as
a theory you know he beat up Steve
Belichick or he he was weed or a concert
or curfew or you know tampered with the
elections in 2016 I mean they've they've
tried everything to pin on this guy and
nothing has really stuck to this point
so the totality is we don't know but the
man played 98 percent of the snaps
during the regular season and then is
benched for the entire Superbowl looks
up you know one specialties play and
then Dan Shawnee the ball dad
Shaughnessy of the Boston Globe back
here in the Rich Eisen show you were
part of the media crew as well that was
trying to crack Belichick on answering
what Jennifer entus revealed in her her
mmq be profile of Jimmy Garoppolo that
Belichick texted him congratulations
after every win that Garoppolo had last
year that's five texts for the San
Francisco 49ers and to say that maybe
he's he's still like John Cusack with
that boom box outside his window is
there any there on that front he kind of
dodged in the same way dan yeah the
Globus Ben Bowlin what tried that route
later on in the presser and bill didn't
didn't it I coulda been you know said is
it true and then followed up with
something and Bill did not answer the is
a true part he just said
he's not thinking about eight months ago
or whatever I mean this would be great
if we could all live our lives and say
well I'm not thinking about what
happened before it's just about now you
know I mean that would be a great way to
go through life because you'd never be
accountable for anything except what's
ahead fresh start all the time and again
he's just a football coach it's just
football but he did not deny that it
strikes me is a lot and uncharacteristic
and it's coming from Garoppolo
parents so I don't think there's any
reason for them to to not be truthful on
that and it just speaks to certain you
know I mean the best face you can put on
this is that it appears that you know
Bill had he worked on the line of
succession here he got the next guy
drafted developed the next guy was ready
and Tom kind of outlived the succession
plan which is nobody's fault but it
brought things to a head when it wasn't
expected that would happen and and they
had to make a decision and they went
they went with the tried and true and
steady old guy well I mean I guess then
we're all comes down I mean Belichick is
when it all said and done a human being
right I mean if this was say Dick
Vermeil sending a text to a former
player who he traded we'd be like well
that's Vermeil just reaching out to
players I mean maybe Belichick does have
that warm side in iment and he and he
really does appreciate Jimmy G and he's
you know he's a handwritten note guy for
a lot of people too but I guess then it
all comes down to this is what does this
all mean for 2018 right I mean well
because I mean that's though I'll give a
two-prong answer I mean these things I
believe they're real and they're true
and I think Patriots fans have a right
to be asking how are we being served
here I mean you love Jimmy G but you
gave him away for a second-round pick
and that guy that was a big asset had a
lot of value there why didn't they get
more and you know if you're talking to
read the the Shanahan quotes nothing
they couldn't believe it was being
offered in one phone call will give you
this guy for a second-round her and how
quick can we do this just that kind of
thing and of course you know a lot of
success thus far with that but to answer
your your real question on this is no I
mean they're going to get where they
want to get in my view
it affects noting that in January
there'll be certainly in a in the final
four I mean they're gonna be an AFC
championship game they just they're in
the worst division in the history of
sports in my view and it's not like they
go six oh no I'm not talking about
beaten at the other three three times or
twice each but that there's never a
challenge in the division they know
showing up that they're going to win the
division this will be like I don't know
16 out of 17 years or some ridiculous
number the other three are always
reinventing themselves new coach new
quarterback and so that's a luxury to
never have a challenge from within your
division and they certainly know how to
run with that get the first round by
second round home game boom you're in
the AFC Championship and given the
strength or weakness of the conference I
expect that to happen again so unless
Brady somehow it gets hurt something
unexpected happens they will get where
they want to get and really all this
stuff as real as it is doesn't really
matter for them getting to the Final
Four so what was the sense in the room
after you had your for follow-up swings
in the bad game was the sense I you know
I mean everybody down there is sort of
beaten down there they're sort of used
to it and I understand that so you know
this is they just they just beat Adalia
and and no one really tries or it's just
there's no there's no no gain in in
pushing these these sort of narratives
and he's good at it and when you win you
get to do that you know when you're
getting kicked around in Cleveland you
don't get to do that you know talk to
people 20 years ago so if you win then
you can be that guy and and have control
of the room and and not be challenged on
anything so I guess where does he rank
for people that you've interviewed press
conferences all time in the history of
every host in sports than Dan which I
choose not to play the game most of the
time I mean we're like the same age and
I've been through a lot I respect him
and I think he's one of the greatest
coaches who ever lived and I would love
to drive cross country with him I think
he's a fascinating character but he is
not going to give it up he's never going
to issue one more piece of information
other than what his court mandated and
if you ask him if today's Wednesday
he'll he'll just tell you that's
traditionally the day that follows
Tuesday but he's not going to give in
and I understand that and I don't I
don't harbor any bad feelings this is
the dynamic and and I've learned to live
with it I just I choose not to engage
most of the time but I thought today
first day back five and a half months
since that game I've been asked about it
every day of my life since then and you
know I'm a sports guy he's a sports guy
I just thought okay let's just try this
one more time
Danah I'd like to do did you
purposefully use the do your job line I
mean that's absolutely you know you got
to come with you got to come armed to
these things originally I just so you
know and that's the truth and that's
what our job is and we can't lose sight
of the fact as much as folks may not
like it but in this case I will say this
is really the first time there's been
pushed back from the fan base on really
anything he's done yeah I had a fourth
and - and a punt and different things
but but this is the one that has stuck
because there are fans here who really
think that it cost him the Super Bowl
and I'm not going to go that far but it
was pretty you know contested game I
mean they lost a Super Bowl gaining 613
yards the quarterback like 505 never
punting and they lost the game almost
impossible well and in the last one for
you ask the poll question to Dan because
it's interesting that you say Dan that
this is the the most shaken the in bill
We Trust Foundation has ever been shaken
it really was about a minute from being
shaken at the the Super Bowl that
Malcolm Butler made the interception
because it without that interception
everyone asked him why didn't bill call
timeout a timeout was there a timeout
yes so a stick I know they either dodged
one arrow they were so brilliant and
such a great read across the field of
the nurse guy over there that they they
were genius again that's the polka yes
so Dan what's the most shocking Super
Bowl coaching moved Seahawks throwing on
the goal line there or bill benching
Butler oh no a Pete Carroll retired the
trophy with the ultimate act of
stupidity where they said Pete you just
won the Super Bowl he said I don't think
so I'm gonna try a slant pass over the
middle instead yeah and that's the isn't
it amazing the Malcolm Butler's involved
in both I know it's like it's iconic of
these Dan thanks the call very
interesting press conference today as
always
Thanks take care thank you guy that's
Dan Shaughnessy the Boston Globe the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience